>> So now we're going to look at a persona that
we can use for our pizza app, and we're going
to call her Dorm Room Debbie. So this is going
to be an, a good example so you can learn how
to use personas in the apps that you design in
the future. So let's look at Dorm Room Debbie's attributes. She's
a college student. She doesn't have a lot of money.
She lives in a dorm. And Debbie doesn't have a car.
>> This looks like a really good persona. Because it seems to be representative
of college students. Most of them don't have a lot of money, and probably
don't have cars, and live in dorms, so.
>> Yep. Exactly. It looks like a very accurate
attribute for that type of user. And it's really important
to mention that you shouldn't denature attributes. And what
that means is try and put in an incompatible attribute,
within Debbie's list. So, if we put something in
there that really wouldn't make sense with the rest of
them it makes the persona really imprecise and it doesn't
make a good product. Let's take a look at three
additional attributes and see which one doesn't fit with the rest.